the White House is doubling down on a
new border hoax two years after falsely
accusing border agents of whipping
migrants the administration is now
falsely claiming Texas governor Greg
abot for the tragic drowning deaths of
three migrants last week a mother and
her two children drowned in the Rio
Grand while attempting to cross the
border the White House not waiting for
the facts instead blasting out a
statement that claims that Texas
officials quote blocked border Agents
from attempting a rescue by shutting
down a part of a public park and of
course the liberal media ate up every
word in Texas the Republican Governor uh
prevents uh Federal officials from
trying to rescue a woman and her two
children who drown trying to cross a
river in Texas agents were physically
barred by Texas authorities from
entering the area he's been talking
about how Texas has done everything
except shoot these migrants and it
almost sounded as though lamenting so he
let them drown his Troopers his forces
are preventing Federal officials uh law
enforcement from saving a life or lives
in this case these are families these
are mothers children I just I I it I am
actually just disgusted with where we
have landed here but it was all a lie
Border Patrol was never blocked from
saving them Biden's own Department of
Justice confirming the three migrants
drowned 1 hour before border patrol even
arrived at the gate to informed Texas
and Texas officials are asking the Biden
Administration to correct the record
about the migrant drownings but the
White House is standing by the smear our
statement is consistent with doj's
filing as the doj filing said there was
an ongoing emergency situation that
border patrol was blocked from accessing
there are other migrants in the water
then why wasn't that included in the
stat other migrants in the water that
that's what you were refering to our
statement ises is very very much
consistent with doj filing anything else
specific you want to know about that I
would certainly refer you to
doj all right um Jesse the White House
is lying here like they lied about whip
gate uh a couple years ago and they get
away with it and there are no
consequences and most of the uh print
media won't even write a correction no
they recycle the propaganda that's the
game there's so many hoaxes just in the
last couple weeks remember dictator on
day one the Seal Team Six assassination
Squad Mara lago's only $18 million Biden
only talks to Hunter's clients about the
weather Trump wants the economy to crash
I mean that's just the last couple weeks
off the top of my head now you have that
these people were drowning and Abbott
blocked Biden's lifeguards from a rescue
we are going to face judge such a
torrent of disinformation this election
year it's going to be a struggle and as
they recycle the propaganda they all
tell us in the media don't do your own
research remember Phil bump Washington
Post the guy that scrambled out of the
podcast when he didn't know what the
heck he was talking about with the
laptop he just prints this piece today
doing your own research is a good way to
end up being
wrong now this guy's a journalist who
believes everything the government tells
him and then writes it all down Philip
bump is always wrong because he never
does his research now as a
journalist I am constantly issuing
clarifications when I get new
information like if something is said by
Harold or Jessica and then in the
commercial break we find out they're
wrong I next block issue a
clarification for the sake of the show
because we don't want any disinformation
out here if Biden judge really wanted to
secure the border and stop the deaths he
would stop the Asylum craziness he would
stop handing out free iPhones bus
tickets and Asylum to everybody in the
third world what they want to do and
this is not me saying this this is the
Democrats saying this they want people
to pick the crops they want people to
have babies and they want to turn Texas
blue again not me saying it that's them
and why are they attacking Greg Abbott
because he's in a
wheelchair that's probably why they're
doing this ableists
all right Harold doesn't having an open
border an automatic uh Catch and Release
with a bus a plane uh and a ferry
available and At Your Service doesn't
that end up promoting illegal
immigration and the deadly consequences
that we're seeing here it's good to be
here um two things one it does all those
things um I was pleased to see I think
the most important thing for me there's
no excuse for uh when things when you
can get things wrong but when you're
confronted with the fact you should you
should say the truth just like I think
about Texas the the most horrible thing
that's happened in Texas one of the
things nothing to do with politics it
was that shooting at that school um and
they didn't get the facts right at first
they kept telling things and you and I
were commenting about in yaldi Texas so
the White House should be candid about
what they got right what they didn't get
right what I'm most and I hope you don't
have to correct me on this uh what I'm
most concerned about in in the coming
hours it looks as if Republicans and
Democrats met at the White House in the
last hour uh and the Republican
leadership in the house came out
uh and they generally speak I think
sometimes politicians do in superlatives
they didn't this time they came out and
said look we we stood our ground we
shared the president we want it and they
made it sound like something positive
might have happened or didn't they
didn't say anything negative happened
and the Democrats came out and said
something similar if we want these
things to stop if we want a different
policy all the things we've talked about
at this table it's got to be our elected
officials who come around the proverbial
table at the White House and in Congress
uh and get something done so I'm
encouraged uh by what they've done uh I
tell you there's a guy though who got my
my blood rolling a little bit earlier
who I think does not have the right to
be around the table in Congress there a
congressman from Texas named Congressman
Nels I hope I'm pronouncing his name
correctly he was quoted a few days ago
saying let me tell you I'm not willing
to do too damn much right now to help a
Democrat and to help Joe Biden's a
dismal approving ratings I will not help
the Dems try to improve this man's
approval ratings why would I sir you got
elected to congress any Democrat that
utters this nonsense or republican Jud
you you can all you want I don't think
this is what people in politics should
be doing you should always be and solve
problems I hope he comes to the table
with his Republican friends and Democrat
friends and Democrats who make equally
Asin on comments like we saw someone not
want to correct the record here at the
beginning of the show you have to call
balls and Strikes everywhere we want
answers to our border Congress has to
act and the president has to act hope
they will are you saying that no
Democrat ever said that that he was
going to criticize and stop Donald Trump
from doing everything he could do during
the Donald Trump years come on don't act
like it's just one side and not and not
the other well judge not only did I not
only am I not saying that I'm
criticizing Democrats I criticize Kar
Jean Pierre I'm just I call balls and
Strikes and I think we all should all
right uh Dana 18% approval rating Biden
has on immigration all he's got to do is
enforce the law he doesn't need Congress
and when when Iowa's 40% immigration is
the biggest issue how much trouble is he
in and also there was an an informal
poll taken uh amongst the Republican
conference yesterday absolute number one
issue is the board
way more than the economy but they're
not alone the Democrats are joining them
in that and one thing that you could
point to so KLA Harris was named the
borders are 1,29 days ago she goes she
goes on The View like we're going to
talk about that this is not an issue
that she's ever asked about or has to
deal with and it was it is the main
issue driving their approval numbers
down and everything else is coming down
along with that of course immigration
being a big issue as well the only thing
you have to do at the White House is
acknowledge there's a problem and try to
fix it why did you R to run for Congress
anyway but they have incentivized the
migrants to come and that is being
helped also by Blue State Governors like
governor nsome who says okay well free
health care is here for you as well then
you start to read some of these stories
about how there's migrants standing
outside in this cold with no coats I
have um family that is helping in Denver
Colorado at nonprofits trying to figure
out a way how can we get them some warm
enough clothes because they care about
the human condition and the Biden
Administration is so willing to lie
about their own
citizens you think about the Texas state
patrol or border patrol that the state
uh folks there that they were accusing
of letting these people die they're
American taxpaying citizens and you
think about Governor Abbott he's put up
with so much and especially being
attacked because he a wheelchair that is
just a little bit too far uh anyway I
would just say that these poll numbers
18% imagine just trying even to get it
to 30% that would just be like a little
drop in the bucket but they're not
willing to do anything if I were the
White House I would have said our bad
sorry got bad information and then you
can move on now they won't be able to no
and they won't go ahead Greg yeah if I
didn't know any better I think the White
House has a pretty low opinion of
Americans who actually every day try to
save the lives that are put at risk by
the the white house so I I go back and I
I listen to this story and it's
obviously we go through a lot of these
stories but it reminds me that the two
most consequential words of the last
eight years was fake news because I
think that you can't listen to these
stories again the same way when you hear
them you hear them differently when I
see the Montage of them uh figting
outrage I know they don't care that
MSNBC crew of clowns they don't care
about those victims right those are just
products for their script and they're
Greatful that they've got it and they
can create a script around it the good
news is I don't think the LIE can travel
around around the world before the truth
comes out I think right now we have an
educated public that can see this even
though it seems like the Dems have have
hired Jesse M Smet as a campaign advisor
because every single one of their
stories is a hoax it's a hate crime hoax
and if it's if you accuse somebody of a
crime that has some kind of racial
component wouldn't The hoax also be a
hate crime what about the people that
are accused of this up what about the
the the whip gate guys they never got a
formal apology I mean you could
conceivably ruin people's lives by
saying you those those three people died
on your watch you that could ruin
somebody's life why is there no
punishment for that I don't get it but
these stories repeat themselves because
like you said uh there's no disincentive
you rely on the media to amplify the
story while bearing bearing the
debunking so these scumbags at MSNBC can
destroy a person's life call them a
murderer but when they're exposed they
don't even make a retraction or if they
do it's days away or it's on page 23 B7
whatever and yet if any of us said
anything anything or any politician
Republicans said anything that would be
slightly problematic they would ruin you
in an instant they would ruin you in an
instant in this case they say some
really horrible things I am heartened
though that this isn't going to fly
anymore this year you look at ex's
community not you see how quickly people
respond they can't get away with this I
couldn't watch that Montage with going
no one's taking that seriously no one
believes that the only reason it
traveled so quickly was CU it blew up
over the weekend yeah cuz they would
have asked them the next day at the
White House briefing also Shifty shift
fundraised off it immediately of course
very good all right hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now